こんにちは はじめしゃちょーと （日本語字幕作成者：今日の一言）
アバンティーズの
そらちいと
ツリメと
リクヲと
エイジです
そらちぃ：はじめさんあなたお菓子を禁止していますよね？
そんなはじめさんに唯一食べられるアイスが登場しました
えぇ！？
それがこちらです
はじめ：いやいやお菓子でしょう
そらちぃ：お菓子じゃないです
解説（そらちぃ）：こちらのアイスボックス１カップあたり13kcalしかない優れもので
はじめ：優れものなんですね？
そらちぃ：そうです
そらちぃ：お菓子じゃないんですよ
はじめ：お菓子じゃないんすか？
そらちぃ：だって考えてくださいよ
はじめ：ないっすね
砂糖が入ってないんだね
グレープフルーツ果汁がメインなので
はじめ：結局僕の目安でやってるから
はじめ：砂糖が入ってなかったら俺はこれはお菓子じゃないと思う
はじめ：まーでも一応ね怖いのでSEIKINさんに許可を貰いましょう
SEIKIN：クゥ～～～～～
SEIKIN：やっぱりねアイスボックスはさっぱりしてて美味しいっすね～
SEIKIN：はじめ君
SEIKIN：これアイスボックス美味しいから食べた方がいいんじゃない？
SEIKIN：そうか今はじめ君お菓子食べれないのか
SEIKIN：いやでもね
SEIKIN：これはねぇ食べた方がいいんじゃないかと思うよ
SEIKIN：今回はこれちょっといっとこう
SEIKIN：アイスボックスOK!!
SEIKIN：ということでまたお会いしましょうSee you next time
*拍手の嵐*
素晴らしい！素晴らしい！
ありがとうございます！本当にありがとうございます
というわけでSEIKINさんから許可もいただいております
今回は特別にこちらを食べていきたいと思います
こちらのアイスボックス
氷なので水と比べて熱をすごく早く奪うので体のクールダウンにつながります
というわけで今回このアイスボックスが水より本当に体を冷やす効果があるのかどうかを検証していきたいと思います
というわけで今回２つ準備しました
アイスボックス入りの炭酸水と
ただの水
この２種類を飲んでる人のどっちが暑さに強いかを今回検証していきたいと思います
はじめ：アバンティーズはどっちにするかい？
エイジ：選べるんすか？
はじめ：水とアイスボックスだったらどっちが
はじめ：まあ大人の事情でちょっと僕がどうしてもね
エイジ：むかつくはまじでｗ
はじめ：というわけで僕は炭酸水入りのアイスボックスで
アバンティーズは水で今回検証していきたいと思います
はじめ：水の方がよかったかな・・・
はいというわけで保湿保温するためにレインコートを皆着ました
今からこの部屋をサウナルームにするためにこちらにアルミホイルやらカイロやら照明.やかん,暖房31℃
全てにおいてこの部屋を完全に暑い部屋にするために
色々な物を準備しました
ひとまずサウナルームを作っていきましょう
はいというわけでサウナルーム完成しましたお疲れ様です
はじめ：どうすか？
エイジ：すでに・・・すでにギブアップですよ
はじめ：これで今から僕はアイスボックスを飲んで
他の４人は水を飲んで
どっちが長くこの暑さに耐えられるかを検証したいと思います
アイスボックスは炭酸と相性がいいので炭酸水を準備しました
はじめ：でも冷え冷えだね
ツリメ：”そら”の結構冷えてないか？
冷気出てる　冷気出てんじゃん
そらちぃ：あっつ！
はじめ：お疲れ様でした　かんぱーーい
はじめ：皆さんどうすか水は
うまい　うまい　うまいねこれは
アイスボックスも美味しいんですよ
はじめ：もう涼しくなったこっちわ
はじめ：もう結構余裕ですよ
エイジ：いやそれは結果を見してもらわないと
はじめ：そうだね　ここから戦いですからね
というわけで只今の温度
エイジ：それに更にカイロ付けてるし
ツリメ：貼りますか？カイロ
ツリメ：いいんですか？
はじめ：もう多分ねアイスボックスのせいでいけるから
はじめ：それくらいハンデでも大丈夫
まじで言ってるんすか？
はじめ：全然いい
はじめ：まじで？多分いけるは俺
ツリメ：うわ！？体熱っ
はじめ：これでどうだ？
はじめ：俺こんな感じで背負ってても絶対勝つから水に
はいというわけで検証がスタートしてから３０分経ちました
はじめ：そろそろ限界っすか？
アバンティーズ：まだいけるじゃねーか　まだ全然いけます
もし本当に限界になった時は
こちらに皆さんの分のアイスボックスを準備しました
これを持って隣の部屋のクーラーの効いた部屋に行ってください
はじめ：危ない危ない
エイジ：まだいけますよ
というわけでツリメ君脱落
というわけで残りの３人もやばいと思ったらアイスボックスを持ってあちらの方でリタイアしてください
リクヲ：辛いんだったらしょうがない
はじめ：わ！脱いだぞー脱いだぞー
そらちぃ：お前らじゃあな
お疲れ様そらちぃギブアップ
さあここからは３人の勝負です
エイジ：俺らで頑張ろう
はじめ：さらっと行くな～
はじめ：正直まだいける？正直まだいける？
リクヲ：あともうちょっといきましょうか
はじめ：もうちょいいこう
*発狂*
1145141919810~
～＾ED＾～
はいというわけでアイスボックス
僕が飲んだ炭酸水以外にもジュースとかコーラでも合います
はいというわけで熱い季節になってまいりました
外に出るとすごい汗をかくと思うし
熱中症とかとても危ないので
水よりも体を冷やす力が強いので
とても熱中症対策になると思います
是非皆さんアイスボックス食べてみてください
では皆さん最後乾杯して終わりましょう
では皆さんかんぱーーい！！
ツリメ：これ美味しいね